eddie what do you think about what's
going on with uh what uh you know
general milly said i i don't know it was
a month ago or something he got up and
he explained crt and the direction
military is going i had uh the former
space force commander on and he was
fired from his position because of the
certain things he wrote in his book you
know with uh
when i was in 97 i i didn't you and i
are one year apart i think you were 79
baby i'm a 78 baby i think you're uh are
you on may 29th when are you may uh
may 29th
may 29th yeah my uh my daughter is may
27 so may 29th so gemini by the way part
of a very interesting camp tupac big e
jfk
marilyn monroe you know
uh elvis presley brad pitt angelina
jolie like you got a very interesting
camp you're a part of you know
say that again
you know you're gemini's yeah i know i
have to i mean gemini's are very
interesting very creative how they are
but
um
you know what do you think about what
direction military's going right now
what general milly's been talking about
dude i on it honestly uh
i saw what general milly said and you
know he doesn't believe what he's saying
you know these these leaders and this is
i think people have to understand this
you know these officers
once they hit a certain rank in the
military uh and i don't quote me on this
but i believe it's like oh four oh five
they have to get uh congress to sign off
on their promotion right
so what what happens then they it
becomes political so these these con
congressmen or women are like okay well
if you you know about baldoni and like
push our agenda we'll sign off on you
getting promoted and so when they reach
these high levels where millie's at you
know he's still doing the same thing
he's conforming to whatever the
current administration wants and
it's not about what's best for the
military it's about what's best for
general milley and that's that's the
problem i'm seeing right now in the
military is that you have these officers
who are being negligent in their duties
which is to take care of the military
take care of the enlisted below them but
instead they're trying to they're taking
care of themselves first
wow so after a certain level all 405
they need congress's signature so if you
don't say the right thing you're not
going to get the promotion anyways
yeah that's and that's why we call
officers at that level of politicians in
uniform
wow so let me ask you who did you guys
respect like amongst the navy seals who
at that general is there anybody they
would say that was a bad mo you know
that was a bad move for anybody that you
guys looked at
at that level that the
folks like you respected a lot
yeah you know admiral mcguire he was i
mean that guy was amazing he was just
recently on uh jocko's podcast just a
very level-headed uh
take care of the boys type of mentality
no matter what rank he had he you know
he was always making sure the guys were
taken care of uh their needs were taken
care of which is what a leader is
supposed to do um
you know and then you you have uh
you know i i know you know i didn't work
with jocko but uh i had
you know friends that did and jacob put
us through training i respected him as
an officer when i was going through you
know and i'll tell you what the best
officers that i've ever worked for are
mustangs they're prior enlisted and then
they decide to become an officer um that
way they know both parts uh and they're
the most level-headed ones um
you know and there's there's definitely
a lot of good good officers out there
unfortunately in the military it's you
know if one officer above you tells you
to conform and obey well in the military
we're told to follow orders and that's
exactly what's going to happen and
that's just going to trickle down to
everybody else that's a scary sight
buddy
it is so if you like this sort of short
clip from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]